as if donald trump needed
any more scandals this could be the
scandal
of all scandals we have learned that the
justice department
is investigating a possible cash for
trump pardons scheme
understand what this means the idea is
there are people out there who want to
be pardoned by donald trump before trump
leaves office in about seven weeks
the idea that is being investigated
is that you could pay someone to go and
talk to trump
about pardoning you and it is absolutely
and utterly insane
we knew trump would issue corrupt and
cronyistic pardons he did so with
michael flynn last week
he did so with roger stone some months
ago
but a cash for pardons scandal is
another level altogether and we learned
about the existence of this
investigation
because of the release of some very
redacted court documents that call this
a
bribery for pardon scheme a ton of the
18-page document that was released
a ton of it is blacked out it's redacted
entire swaths
large sections even almost whole pages
blacked out
nobody who is involved has yet been
named
uh in the redacted documents presumably
they are named in the unredacted
documents
but what the document does say is that
federal prosecutors in washington say
they've obtained evidence of a
bribery scheme in which someone would
offer
a big political contribution in exchange
for a presidential pardon or reprieve of
sentence the order said prosecutors were
also investigating a secret lobbying
scheme
in which two unidentified individuals
would lobby senior white house officials
about pardons without uh disclosing that
without being registered properly as
part of the lobbying disclosure act
the justice department wanted to keep
this private because it detailed
individuals and conduct that hasn't yet
led to charges
and it is an absolutely insane series of
allegations now i want to be really
clear
just because the pardons would
ultimately be issued by donald trump
doesn't mean that this was people giving
trump money for pardons it's really
important that we understand that
it wouldn't be surprising to me given
trump's massive debts
if people were offering trump money for
pardons that's not what we as of now
believe is going on the idea for now
seems to be
that if you want a pardon you pay
someone
that someone goes and talks to senior
white house officials
the idea being the white house officials
then go to trump
and maybe never disclose that there is
this whole
bribery situation going on and say hey
sir mr president you should really look
at pardoning this person or that person
so it's still very early
but my mind goes to how
bad must this be if donald trump's
own attorney general william barr's doj
is investigating and what i mean by that
is william barr is one of the most
corrupt attorneys general we've ever
seen in terms of political cronyism and
partisanship
even william barr had to say there's no
evidence of widespread voter fraud which
we covered
earlier today i can't imagine that
william barr would be eager to bring
charges for criminal pardon
bribery but for william barr to even
have his justice department
investigating this means that there
has been a relatively high threshold met
already
this entire issue of pardons of course
is a bigger issue
you know imagine a president ordering
people to assassinate a political enemy
and then pardoning them as an example um
the
the entire pardon process and
infrastructure
is riddled with uh corruption cronyism
and lends itself to all sorts
all sorts of malfeasance but we are now
getting to investigations that are the
types of things you see more often
in developing and poorer countries not
typically the united states
but it's at least possibly happening
here scandal
after scandal after scandal and
you know we've got seven weeks left what
will we learn about
in these last seven weeks what will
trump do
in these last seven weeks and then once
he's out of office
what are we going to learn i i don't
believe that we will ever see
trump indicted prosecuted or jailed as
many of my viewers would like to see and
as some of my
viewers believe will happen but i do
believe that there is going to be
another shoe that drops
after donald trump is out of office
about all sorts of allegations of things
he
and the people around him did and a lot
of this explains
why donald trump is now considering
pardoning preemptively
his own children son-in-law and rudy
giuliani
we will talk about that after the break
in the meantime
make sure you're following me on
instagram
david.pakman also follow the show on
instagram for more clips
and extra content david pakman show
on instagram privacy.com is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you five
dollars just for using their free
service at
privacy.com pacman privacy is a service
i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month
you can set spending limits freeze them
delete them whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged
in the future if you're ordering food
over the phone why do i need to give a
restaurant my real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman